a growing number of teams have issued
statements indicating that due to
pandemic-related concerns they will
exercise their prerogative
to not participate in
on-field workouts in 2021 this has been
an issue that's lingered for a while jc
treader the president of the union wants
to get rid of the
on-field off-season workouts all
together the number of teams now up to
10 that means 22 have yet to speak i
wonder how many of those teams have
decided matt we're good we're going to
show up for the voluntary offseason
program because look peter
i don't think the union really knows
what the reason is i think there are
multiple different reasons for it we're
going to talk about that but the bottom
line is
players are going to work out somewhere
they're not going to sit home and do
nothing they're going to try to get
ready for training camp the question is
are they going to work out at the team
facility and be protected against any
injury they may suffer are they going to
stay home and ride the exercise bike and
do push-ups and put in the old p90x dvds
if you get injured there you're not
covered they're going to go to planet
fitness and lift weights there drop a
weight on your foot bust your toe you're
not covered go to the local high school
field step on a rock pop in achilles
you're not covered i hope the union is
explaining to these guys the risk
they're taking
if they exercise anywhere
other than in the team facility you're
putting your entire salary on the line
for 2021 if you do that so unless you're
going to sit home and i'll say this to
all the players out there
all three of them that may be watching
and i'm probably i'd take the under um
understand the risk you're taking if you
are exercising anywhere but
the team facility and that's one of the
reasons why i think his players
understand this peter look it's
admirable to take a stand i support the
union generally i just think this isn't
it
yeah i mean we'll see mike this is a
this is an interesting a very
interesting little conflict and
you could tell
last fall when jc treader began to talk
about
how we need to totally remake
the off-season
in the nfl
you know this has been a fantastic
season
for you know health and well-being
of players so the way i look at this is
this a little bit of the union flexing
its muscles
and saying to the nfl look
these workouts are voluntary and so
we're not going to come if we don't want
to come and there's absolutely nothing
you can do about this
i think one of the key things about this
and why it is such an interesting
time in the union and in the
relationship between players and and and
management in the nfl
is mike think about this
okay
1019 players
voted to approve
the new collective bargaining agreement
that included the 17th game
969 players voted against it that on
average is two players per locker room
that was the margin
you know
60 votes is the margin so you've got a
tremendous
number of players on both sides and you
know what i think of whenever i see each
one of these
uh statements from teams
i think of those
969 players
i think of alvin kamara i think of the
ticked off guys
at the 17th game
and i think hey listen
we're going to show up and we're going
to play and we're going to be there 47
days before the start of the season for
opening a training camp beyond that
we're not doing anything that we don't
have to do
i love that in theory peter and i think
there's so much imbalance in the
relationship anyway between the league
and the union because the league will
use the nuclear option of lost games to
a work stoppage whether it's a lockout
or a strike or if it's a strike they'll
just use replacement players and keep
going the players won't as we learned in
1987 hold together in the face of a work
stoppage that takes away game checks i
just think there's a huge disconnect
between the collective desire to give
the owners a middle finger
and the individual
issues that are going to arise jc trader
made the comment earlier this week to
rich eisen that the notion
as articulated by bruce arians that this
is just a matter of veterans not wanting
younger players to get an opportunity to
show that they can take roster spots
treader called that an effort to divide
the union no it's not it's a recognition
of the inherent divisions this is a
unique workforce you got 90 guys per
team now
ultimately 90 once they add the draft
picks and the undrafted free agents it's
going to whittle down to 53. 37 guys are
going to be gone now some of them will
be on the practice squad but they're not
getting the full game checks they're
competing for those spots so at some
point peter the individual impetus to be
one of the 53 is going to win out you're
going to have young players particularly
who understand there's an opportunity
here and if the other players are upset
with me i don't care the coach is happy
with me and he's the one who decides
whether or not i'm on the team not these
other guys who are mad at me and some of
them may end up getting cut anyway
because they're not here
that's the problem that this entire
approach is inviting so again i firmly
believe i love it i love to see the
union flexing its muscles the problem is
they're going to throw out
a lumbar disc in the process because
it's going to expose and yet again
reinforce the idea that collective
action by this union can't work because
there's too many guys whose best
interests are going to be
get your ass into the building and show
up i mean peter plain and simple once
you understand because you these guys
are not going to sit on the couch and
watch tv they're going to work out once
they understand that if they get injured
away from the facility they don't get
paid this season if they get injured in
the facility it's basically free
insurance against that fluke injury that
may happen i think once they understand
that
this isn't going to hold together
mike you talk about the the 37 guys per
team we're going to be gone it really
isn't that because practice squads this
year are going to be somewhere between
14 and 60 they don't get paid they don't
get paid
right i understand they don't get paid
the same but what i'm talking about is
they still are allowed to vote and they
still are allowed to express their
opinions
you know in terms of
you know what what their team is going
to do so the only point i'm making in
this about this is that
there are there there is a gigantic
middle and lower class
in the national football league that in
my opinion hugely
influenced the the vote for the last cba
and mike if that vote doesn't pass
i believe right now hey there's no way
you have 113 billion dollar media
agreements that uh they signed last
month
absolutely no way
and you know what else they don't have
they don't have labor piece
they would not have gotten a deal done
and so right now i believe you would be
either in a lockout or on the verge of a
lockout and this season would be
in total disarray
and i think all that is because the
middle and lower class players basically
stampeded to the ballot box
and won this
uh
you know won this
election you know for a new cba
you know much to d smith's pleasure and
so right now i think you're seeing the
results of that because i just think
there's a lot of
big players and big time players who are
still ticked off over that and who still
say and who say we're not giving the nfl
any cooperation on this and i see your
point you have a really good point about
if they get hurt working out somewhere
you know they're they're screwed
but i still think that the first
reaction is going to be we're not
helping management at all
oh and i agree with you there and as
this settles in that's when it begins to
crumble you know peter the way that the
nfl has set up the offseason schedule
this year is conducive to undermining
the resolve of the veteran players
because phase two
of the off-season program may 17 that
week it also consists of the rookie mini
camps and that comes before there's ever
an opportunity for the players to not
show up for on-field work in phase three
that comes the next week so before the
players can ever
truly flex their muscles and have an
empty locker room on the day that
they're going to practice for the first
time in the offseason before that occurs
you'll have the draft picks you'll have
the undrafted free agents you'll have
all the tryout
participants and there will be many of
them
at the rookie mini camp there's 40 50
guys that show up for this rookie mini
camp that's going to happen in 32 teams
before we ever get to the point
where the veterans don't show up and you
know what's going to happen we're going
to see all this footage of practice and
we're going to have quotes from coaches
and the average person who's paying
minimal attention to this is going to be
thinking well i thought well there went
that nflpa boycott thing there's all
these guys practicing i mean it's gonna
it's gonna undermine the resolve of the
veterans before we even get to day one
of this
of this legitimate and permissible
boycott of voluntary offseason workouts
and and who's going to be there for
phase three for the start of the
traditional on-field workouts it's going
to be the undrafted free agents most of
the draft picks and whoever happens to
get a job via the tryout portion of the
rookie mini camp they're going to be
there so while the veterans are home
either doing nothing or risking their
salaries by working out at planet
fitness product placement for no reason
whatsoever the young guys are going to
be there getting the reps currying favor
with the coaching staff and it's not
going to take long just like it reminds
me of the 87 strike and the scabs from
87 are the undrafted players
and the rookies
in 2021. after a week or two of that at
most
the veterans are going to come back
because they're going to realize the
train's going to keep rolling without
them and they're making it even harder
for themselves to make the 53-man roster
if all these young guys are there
getting the first team reps
mike let me ask you a question
suppose
that the union went to management right
now and said
you know as of right now
you know
a new coach uh in this season right a
new coach could have had his players
in-house i think the date was april 6th
it was somewhere right around there and
and then it was pushed back two weeks
right but
why don't
players
and and management why isn't there a
compromise where you say
no player in any facility pick a date in
may no player goes to any facility until
let's say may 10th
okay so it gives the players in essence
another month where they're basically
free of any obligations
so to me that might be a compromise
if i am a veteran player that i would
appreciate even more but what what are
the pros and cons of that in your mind
well i think one of the realities is
my understanding is there's already 400
players who are actively showing up on a
regular basis and working out at the
team facility because they can because
they understand the benefit of doing it
there working out on their own uh for a
variety of reasons they're allowed to do
so as of right now the full
gathering of the players doesn't happen
until the week of may 24 anyway that's
what's so confusing about this when i
saw the nfl's full
schedule
for the offseason program as it was
proposed to the union and the union said
no thank you i look at it and i say
what's the problem with it see
this is the thing that gnaws at me peter
because
the nflpa doesn't have one cohesive
explanation for why it's doing what it's
doing the surface level is the pandemic
well it's not the pandemic you know if
you're concerned about the pandemic
number one go get vaccinated number two
why do you have an issue with the league
using yeah but what but then beyond that
even if you don't get a vaccine why all
of a sudden do you have an issue with
the exact same protocols that you agreed
to last year for training camp regular
season post season the same protocols
apply when the players are there for the
on-field workouts why do you hate those
now we've never gotten an answer to that
because i think the pandemic is being
used as cover for
one this is a middle finger to the nfl
for having the upper hand in the
relationship the rebellion against the
17 game season and two guys like jc
trader don't want any offseason program
under any circumstance pandemic's a
convenient thing to point to but the
pandemic isn't the reason why they're
doing this so it's creating this
impression
that
that they re you know you're not gonna
sell this unless you've got a rallying
cry that everyone understands the
rallying cry collectively is not going
to overcome the rallying cry in each of
these guys houses
when they're getting tough questions
from
spouse significant other parent
agent why the hell aren't you at work
what are they going to say why aren't
you there well they told me not to go
well why
well i don't know they didn't want to go
but why
it's not going to hold together at that
point and that's when you're going to
start seeing guys crossing a
non-existent picket line
look the last time
that something like this happened or
anything like this happened really is in
1987
when uh the way that
when the nfl hired replacement players
after two weeks of that season to play
games
and
they started actually playing games they
played three weeks with these
replacement players
and the reason that the
that the nflpa solidarity died you know
i remember boomer assistant
you know basically laying down in front
of a bus with the replacement players
you know in cincinnati and the reason
that that died is that guys like
lawrence taylor crossed the picket line
and and and a lot of randy white with in
in dallas a lot of players started
crossing the picket line
and once that happened once name players
decided to go and decided to go in
you know everything crumbled so my
feeling is we'll see they've got 11
teams now and we'll see how solid uh
they're going to be but but in my
opinion i agree mike
that that the nfl last year
saw that you can have
a very good very representative
enjoyable season you know that ended
with some great drama and tom brady went
in the super bowl and brady versus
mahomes it was it was fine it was great
and the nfl has now seen that it can
happen that way and much to the chagrin
of coaches
i really really wonder
the coaches whose jobs are really on the
line
how are they going to handle this like
if i i'm serious what if matt nagy
cannot have andy dalton in for the
entire length of the offseason his job
is on the line andy dalton's job is on
the line in the future as well that's
why i think this is going to be some
interesting drama in the next few weeks
and the coaches
and and we've known this for 20 years it
rarely gets enforced but most coaches
are smart enough to avoid the line
they're not allowed to say or do
anything to suggest that the voluntary
workouts or anything but
however
there's going to be no way to police
whatever coaches say to the agents of
specific players
off the grid talking to them
hey i need your guy here look we've
known each other for a long time we've
done a lot of work together we're going
to continue to do a lot of work together
i value the relationship i'm sure you do
too i need your guy here you got to get
him here and most of the agents are
already wired to get their guys there
the guys who have workout bonuses
they're going to be there the young guys
who are trying to get one of those 53
jobs in one of the spots on the practice
squad they're going to be there because
their agents are going to tell them to
be there and one last point in that
regard peter well two points one
the nfl pa is not going to pressure four
teams whose players have significant
roster bonuses packers bills jaguars
chiefs that in and of itself creates an
inherent division that will attract
players from their competitors to show
up because those teams are all working
and getting ready and secondly we
mentioned that
87 strike i haven't researched this
point of labor law which is the
subtle way that a lawyer says i don't
know the answer to the question i
haven't researched that quite yet
i don't know whether or not you can even
have a picket line when you're talking
about collective action that
isn't a strike it's not a strike it's
just guys exercising their prerogative
under the cba to not show up
voluntarily i wonder if they're gonna
have guys
at or close to the edge of team facility
property
trying to keep guys out i wonder if
they're gonna do that and i wonder if
they even can legally try that that's a
wrinkle of this i hadn't considered but
if they're serious about it
they may have to do whatever they have
to do to keep those guys from getting in
and if you got the veterans lined up out
there and they're eyeballing you and
they're telling you don't go across that
that makes that makes for some drama
that i hadn't really anticipated
i mean that's one of the reasons why
it's going to be an interesting story
because we don't know how it's going to
play out
over the next let's say month
um and it's it it's kind of interesting
the draft is going to be in the middle
of it so this is going to take
a significant back seat i believe mike
in terms of the news cycle and all that
because look
honestly tell me why any fan
should care about this
if i'm a fan i don't care
i was thinking about this yesterday what
am i going to do in my column on monday
about this
and i i mean this is going to be one of
these things that people are just going
to glaze over and they don't care and
they're not going to be passionate about
it
so i really wonder let's say in the next
month if indeed as you say
that players could really get
strong-armed into not showing up
you know
how big of an issue is it going to be
from team to team to team and i think i
i really wonder
i don't think the public cares at all
number one but number two
i wonder about things like team
chemistry
and and how you're gonna build whatever
you're gonna do this season in this
off-season program coaches are going to
figure a way even if
you know the nflpa throws an incendiary
device at the off-season programs around
the league coaches will figure it out
but i do think that this is going to be
a real uncomfortable time for a lot of
teams and players
and you say the fans don't care i think
part of what we do is make them care by
drawing out the angles that are
interesting and that show how things can
collapse and how you can get yourself
into a problem and hey if i'm a bears
fan and i know the packers are going to
be there because the union's not
squeezing them to stay away and they're
going to be getting better and they're
going to be getting ready if i'm a bears
fan i'm not happy with that because my
team's already starting with a hand
behind its back as the packers are
getting ready to you know build on what
they've done the last two seasons
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports